und er ist tot ayman al zawahiri
terrorist al kaida chef der kopf des
internationalen terrors war er jetzt ist
er getötet gezielt durch eine
amerikanische drohne wo auf dem balkon
eines hauses in kabul in der hauptstadt
afghanistans dort also wurde er
ausgelöscht dort haben die us militärs
und die geheimdienste zugeschlagen am
wochenende bereits so wurde es jetzt
bekannt dort also in der hauptstadt
afghanistans dort auf einem balkon ayman
al zawahiri
ausgelöscht die nummer eins von al kaida
getötet
ayman al zawahiri
dschihadist terror schlechter al kaida
anführer doch wer war der mann der bei
seinem tod 71 jahre alt war wirklich er
galt als nachfolger von osama bin laden
war bis zu dessen tod seine rechte hand
unter ihrer gemeinsamen führung führte
al kaida den tödlichsten anschlag aller
zeiten auf amerikanischem boden durch
die anschläge vom 11 september
2001 mit vier passagierflugzeugen
über 3000 menschen starben al sawahiri
war immer bin ladens mentor bin laden
schaute zu ihm auf er war ein
dschihadist seid ihr ein teenager war
der 1951 geborene sawahiri wuchs in
einem wohlhabenden vorort der
ägyptischen hauptstadt kairo auf während
seiner ausbildung zum chirurgen knüpfte
sie kontakte zu radikalen muslim gruppen
mit dem ziel einen islamischen staat in
ägypten zu gründen trat er in den 1970
er jahren der neuen terror gruppe
ägyptischer islamischer jihad bei die
1981 dem präsidenten ermordete zawahiri
wurde festgenommen und blieb drei jahre
in haft ist er 1985 über saudi arabien
nach pakistan aus reiste den ägypter sei
aber hier ii und den in saudi arabien
geborenen bin laden verband der
fanatischer hass auf amerika israel und
die herrschaftsstrukturen in ihrer
jeweiligen heimat
er prägt al-kaida und den jihadismus
ideologisch seinen letzten öffentlichen
auftritt hatte al zawahiri im
vergangenen september
genau 20 jahre nach den anschlägen vom
11 september
die usa hatten auf al zawahiri ein
kopfgeld von 25 millionen dollar
ausgesetzt
jetzt ist er tot
[Musik]
das haben die us-behörden vor wenigen
stunden bekannt gegeben und diese
minuten erlebte unser us korrespondent
herbert bauernebel genau dort und
herbert ich grüße dich dort in die nacht
in die usa du kannst und schultern wie
die usa diese momente erleben ist dass
das ist ja ein alter mann ayman al
zawahiri gewesen also ein
prestige-erfolg nur oder mehr macht das
tatsächlich die welt sicherer
es ist sicher ein prestige-erfolg keine
frage es ist nicht so ganz dramatisch
wie vor zehn jahren als osama bin laden
ausgeschaltet wurde als hier in den
stunden nach der bekanntgabe tausende
menschen am ground zero gestanden sind
aber immerhin war der nachfolger von
osama bin laden er war die nummer eins
von al qaida obwohl man von al kaida in
den letzten jahren jetzt nicht mehr so
viel gehörter für amerika ist es
insofern ein erfolg weil die staatsmacht
hier ist hier eindeutig vorführt wie es
der präsident joe biden gesagt hat man
bei amerika schaden möchte wird gejagt
und amerika werde niemals vergessen und
jetzt sieht man eben das mehr als 20
jahre nach den terrorattacken
eleven jetzt eben al sawahiri
ausgeschaltet wurde eben durch diese
drohne hinzu kommt auch bewunderung in
amerika für die arbeit der geheimdienste
das war eine lang geplante aktion mehr
als sechs monate hat man hier
vorbereitet als man erst mal bemerkt hat
dass al sawahiri nach kabul gezogen ist
und daneben die detaillierten
vorbereitungen es wurde sogar ein modell
des hauses nachgebaut joe biden selbst
hat das inspiziert es wurde hier
herumgetüftelt dass die zivilen opfer
gering bleiben und tatsächlich ist im
alter aber hier in niemand sonst ums
leben gekommen all das ist eine
akribische vorbereitung die hier in den
usa bewundert wird und natürlich der
schlag perfekt ausgeführt werden spricht
die worte des us-präsidenten schamanen
hat sich vor wenigen minuten eben zu
wort gemeldet zu dieser gezielten tötung
ein mann als avaris schauen wir noch mal
rein in die worte des us-präsidenten
die usa haben unter meiner anweisung
einen luftangriff in kabul durchgeführt
bei dem der anführer von al kaida ayman
al zawahiri getötet wurde jetzt wurde
gerechtigkeit gesprochen und diesen
terroristenführer gibt es nicht mehr
menschen auf der ganzen welt müssen den
bösartigen und entschlossenen mörder
nicht mehr fürchten
die vereinigten staaten demonstrieren
weiterhin ihre entschlossenheit und die
fähigkeit das amerikanische volk gegen
diejenigen zu verteidigen die versuchen
und schaden zuzufügen
wir machen heute noch einmal deutlich
dass egal wie lange es dauert egal wo du
dich versteckst wenn du eine bedrohung
für unser volk ist die vereinigten
staaten finden dich und töten dich
ist das so herbert stärkt das auch
diesen präsidenten der ja ja bisher
nicht immer ganz stark rüberkam zuletzt
auch dann noch durch corona zusätzlich
geschwächt war
es ist natürlich ein erfolg für joe
biden der ja in den letzten tagen und
wochen doch immer mehr unter druck
geraten ist besonders wegen der
wirtschaftlichen lage hier in den usa
besonders bezüglich auch der mega
inflation und natürlich ist es für joe
biden ein kleiner etappensieg auch im
bezug auf eine seiner umstrittensten
entscheidungen bisher als präsident eben
den abzug der amerikanischen truppen aus
afghanistan der sehr chaotisch verlaufen
ist im vorjahr und auch sehr tödlich
verlaufen ist und schon hat gesagt dass
seine taktik richtig wäre und er hat das
auch zurückgeführt auf jedem jetzt
diesen schlag gegen al zawahiri er sagte
man brauchte keine truppen am boden in
afghanistan braucht er einfach nur die
lufthoheit
bezüglich solcher schläge von
geheimdiensten aber es ist natürlich ein
wermutstropfen denn was man hier auch
ganz deutlich sieht ist dass die taliban
die afghanistan jetzt regieren wieder al
qaida hier offensichtlich zuschlug
zuschlag gewährt haben wie man eben
sieht man muss sich vorstellen als aber
hier lebte im haus des afghan des
afghanischen innenministers sieht man
einfach die querverbindung genommen was
natürlich ist ein gefundenes fressen
auch für die republikaner die jetzt
sagen diese schlag wäre gleichzeitig
auch ein beweis für das versagen von joe
biden weil jetzt eben die taliban und
al-qaida hier offensichtlich wieder
zusammen arbeiten in afghanistan wir
sehen auf den alten bildern immer wieder
als safari an der seite von osama bin
laden dessen tötung gut zehn jahre
mittlerweile liegt sie zurück im mai
2011 war das damals gingen die bilder um
die welt nicht nur von diesen
nächtlichen drohnen aufnahmen der
gezielten tötung von osama bin laden
sondern auch aus dem weißen haus damals
diese dramatischen sekunden dort im
situation room als der damalige
präsident und seine außenministerin
diese dramatischen minuten dort 40
minuten in afghanistan per video
verfolgt haben das sind die bilder noch
einmal von damals mit ja barack obama
und hillary clinton die dramatischen
sekunden minuten der gezielten tötung
osama bin ladens weißt du etwas über joe
biden hat er das auch live verfolgt
diesmal die tötung ein mann al sawahiris
aus dem weißen haus raus per video
beispielsweise
das kann sie war natürlich wenn es dazu
gekommen sein sollte und genaue details
weiß man noch nicht es wäre
komplizierter und komplexer gewesen denn
joe biden laboriert gerade an einer
kurbel infektion herum er war zuerst da
positiv dann war wieder ein gerät jetzt
wieder positiv so gesehen musste er
das gesamte kommando hier irgendwie aus
der quarantäne heraus mitverfolgen ob es
genau das zu den gleichen ähnlichen
dramatischen moment im situation room
gekommen ist das muss man deshalb
bezweifeln aber klar ist natürlich die
beiden war hier ganz am drücker hat sich
wie gesagt auch ein modell des hauses
zeigen lassen und feiert natürlich jetzt
schon diesem erfolg aufs gesicht und wer
kriegt die 25 millionen dollar kopfgeld
muss man jetzt jeden welcher von den
cia-agenten jetzt herausgefunden hat
dass al zawahiri tatsächlich nach
afghanistan gereist wie eben diese
geheimdienstler eben früher bemerkt
haben danke an unseren us-konsumenten
herbert bauernebel an diesem tag an dem
bekannt wird die usa haben mit militärs
und geheimdienstoffizieren
gezielt getötet die nummer eins auf der
terrorliste von al qaida nämlich einmal
ein alter verrät danke dir herbert
[Musik]